depuis quelques années le mouvement MiTo
a libéré la parole des femmes la parole
des femmes harcelées sexuellement se
libèrent et au-delà de ce simple
hashtags à travers le monde de nombreux
artistes sont soulevés contre les
violences sexuelles faites aux femmes
[Musique]
si Angèle on a fait une chanson elle
n'est pas la seule à s'être engagée pour
cette cause en mars 2021 c'est la
journaliste Marie pour tout l'anneau qui
réalisait un documentaire sur le sexisme
dans le milieu du sport ça me met en
colère face à met en colère que ça
devrait pas exister la musique ne sont
pas les seuls milieux touchés l'actrice
Emma Watson s'était prononcé il y a déjà
longtemps pour plus d'égalité
homme-femme
[Musique]
qui s'est confié sur le sexisme qu'elle
a subi durant sa carrière dans le livre
toute pour la musique écrit par Cloé
Thibault je l'ai toujours ressenti dans
la mesure où si tu regardes le milieu de
la chanson les hommes sont entre eux et
à mon époque c'était encore des gros
machins et pour chez là aujourd'hui les
choses n'ont pas vraiment changé c'est
10 fois plus difficile de réussir dans
ce métier pour une fille que pour un mec
c'est ça qu'il faut savoir et je trouve
que ça n'a pas évolué Julie Gayet Muriel
Robin Victoria Abril elles sont de plus
en plus nombreuses aujourd'hui à faire
entendre leur voix alors selon vous
l'équilibre homme-femme a-t-il évolué
dans les médias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notamment voilà beaucoup de téléréalité
et vous avez beaucoup choisir aussi sur
le sexisme on va pas dans un instant
mais d'abord un petit mot parce que
Natacha mal vous avez connu toutes ces
années et vous le dites aussi dans la
presse vous dites moi si le temps
j'étais passé j'avais été plus
sympathique avec certains producteurs on
va dire dans la chambre d'hôtel j'aurais
peut-être notamment au cinéma vous avez
une belle came et fait une carrière
autrement plus importante oui dans les
années 90 c'était c'était absolument le
cas parce que le j'ai j'étais vraiment
dans la famille cinéma et j'ai fait des
films pas toujours brillantes ici mais
enfin j'en ai fait mais comment ça se
concrétiser mais c'était vraiment c'est
d'abord c'est très classique donc il y a
des clans il y a des familles machin etc
et puis et puis effectivement j'avais
des réalisateurs qui me voulaient qui
nous écoutent voilà je te donne
l'adresse tu vas passer voir le
producteur
et donc j'arrivais dans le bureau du
producteur qui me faisait me lever
marcher faire des petits tours sur moi
pour voir comment j'étais bien foutue et
puis qu'après il me disait vous aimez
jouer au tennis vous aimez et qui
voulait m'emmener en fait en vacances
j'ai pourquoi je dois aller en vacances
avec le type pour jouer dans le film là
je comprends pas bien et puis ça c'était
encore la version la plus sympathique
mais j'ai eu des versions moins
sympathiques ou j'étais blacklisté pour
avoir refusé de blacklister c'était pas
seulement dans un film c'est le même
producteur
à chaque fois que que qu'une casting
directeur me présentait pour un rôle
le producteur a annoncé les deux dents
je le fais pas et donc on a posé la
question effectivement pensez-vous que
l'équilibre homme-femme a évolu dans les
médias il y a tous les oui oui non et
c'est très partagé il dit oui non et
vous donc maïssan vous dites que tout
est encore très sexiste mais dans quoi
dans la téléréalité ou dans les médias
en général
moi je pense que dans les médias en
général ça reste encore très sexiste
mais en revanche dans la téléréalité moi
je suis là depuis trois ans et déjà rien
que sur un espace de 3 ans j'ai vu les
choses évoluer ça veut dire quoi ben
déjà dans la dans les productions il y a
beaucoup plus de femmes qui travaillent
aussi donc il y a une parité déjà dans
la prod du coup forcément les gens ils
sont un peu plus sensibilisés ils font
attention à ce que vous demandez qui
vous choquait des trois premières années
mais c'est vrai qu'au début quand on
quand on nous casse-tête c'était plus
accès sur le physique sur
faire attention à notre projet sur notre
nu etc si on était pudique ou pas
pudique on nous posait ce genre de
questions mais maintenant c'est vous qui
avez fait des photos aussi c'est pas
quand on vous voit là oui très à l'aise
avec mon corps après quand c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui me pose la
question pour aller sur une télé-réalité
ça me gêne mais c'est vrai que ça a
beaucoup évolué et ces dernières années
les producteurs ils ont un peu plus peur
que comme on a une voix plus importante
maintenant qu'on balance qu'on parle de
ce qui nous arrive ben moi j'en entends
plus parler de mettre en avant d'avoir
un petit peu les seins comme ça des
histoires d'amour ce qu'on vous demande
un peu en téléréalité pour exister les
profils qui étaient recherchés après il
nous le demandait pas explicitement ils
sont pas stupides et attention mais
nous-mêmes on ressentait que c'était ce
qu'on devait faire pour exister à
l'écran mais parce qu'avant vous ne
faisez vous ne faisiez pas ça en fait
c'est à dire que ça vous montrer comme
ça on lingerie dénudé c'est pas quelque
chose que vous faisiez quand vous avez
été recruté c'est quelque chose que je
faisais pas moi j'étais à l'école donc
j'avais pas le temps de prendre des
photos en soutif maintenant et vous
aimez le vendre visiblement vous mettez
des photos pour avoir des likes si vous
êtes de la téléréalité mais vous voulez
vraiment la téléréalité qui vous a amené
à être dans ce registre on va dire la
téléréalité ça m'a pas dans un mauvais
sens la téléréalité ça m'a ça m'a amené
à assumer mon corps et à me montrer sans
en avoir très jeune donc la question se
pose pas et vous êtes jeune bien sûr
mais ma question c'est est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on j'ai demandé aussi à
Laurent parce que Laurent mais oui mais
est-ce qu'on accepte de voir tout
simplement des femmes vieillir à
l'antenne que ce soit la télévision ou
au cinéma je le répète encore mais c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment la télévision tous
les hommes reviennent la gaffe Laurent
Pascal Bataille tout le monde revient il
n'y a une femme qui reviennent Christine
Bravo des nombreuses il y a pas une
femme qui reviennent est-ce qu'on veut
voir des vieilles pardon est-ce qu'on
peut voir pardon des femmes non mais je
retire pas un jeu de mots est-ce qu'on
va voir des femmes plus âgées revenir
dans une série où la télévision est-ce
qu'on accepte de voir les vampires mais
c'est un peu vrai ce que vous dites
c'est quoi c'est un peu vrai ce que vous
dites est-ce qu'on accepte de voir les
femmes vieillir en revanche moi ma
théorie c'est faut toujours se placer
sous un axe différent et regardez les
choses sous un axe différent ma théorie
personnelle c'est que j'appartiens à une
génération qui a vu quand même pas mal
d'hommes de mon âge mais être super
frileux de d'aller avec des de vraiment
se mettre en couple et puis créer une
famille
donc prévoir un espèce de long terme
donc on a ensemble etc on vit ensemble
parce que
ils ont commencé à avoir peur de
vieillir eux donc ça conditionnait le
fait qu'ils attendent le plus tard
possible pour trouver éventuellement une
femme plus
là c'est
et vraiment mais vraiment là j'en suis
j'en suis persuadé parce que j'en ai
parlé avec des amis et j'ai une de mes
amis avec qui j'ai parlé hier soir et
elle est avec quelqu'un qui a 20 ans de
plus et elle vient de faire un enfant
avec un type qui a quand même
oui mais à la télé il y a encore
à la télé j'avais demandé aussi à
Valérie Bénin de devenir mais elle est
pas là la campagne j'embrasse mais
miroir d'avoir quelqu'un mais regarde à
la télévision aussi à la télévision
aussi je pensais à Valérie Benaim je
pensais à un épisode plein de fils en
niquetier on les met toujours à côté
d'un homme et on les met pas seul et
Annie toujours dit très bien quand
Christian Morin a quitté la roue de la
fortune on a dit on va remettre un homme
tu tourneras les lettres nous ne mettra
pas de femme c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui
mais ça c'est les décisionnaires qui
genre de choses très différentes sur des
jeux de détails qu'on dit en télé des
jeux journée ou malheureusement il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui regardent ce
genre de jeu la journée etc tu changeras
pas Reichmann pour une femme parce que
voilà tu dis que féminin etc les dames
sont là est-ce qu'on change Jean-Luc
Reichmann contre une femme quel que soit
la femme tout le monde dit non toutes
les femmes disent non c'est ça le public
à un moment donné la télé a pas décidé
que on favoriser les hommes aux femmes
il y a plein d'autres secteurs on
favorise les femmes aux hommes ça dépend
de la la
lame ce que je veux dire c'est que un je
pense pas que la que la que la que le
public soit sexiste après on peut
discuter trois plombes de pourquoi vous
mesdames vous préférez je pense que
public tu sais quoi le public prend ce
qu'on leur donne on mettra une femme à
13h je pense que ça fait la même score
c'est faux alors je peux dire à moi
juste Jean-Mi Jean-Mi après toi
avec Laurent faut pas oublier que tu
donnes une chaîne de télévision c'est
une entreprise qui va faire des
bénéfices et la cible principale c'est
la responsable le responsable et la
responsable des achats qui préfèrent
voir un beau mec même quel que soit son
âge en train de présenter l'émission que
de voir une femme
pour expliquer au public la responsable
des achats c'est la femme généralement
qui est responsable des achats dans le
foyer qui va chez Carrefour et qui a
moins de 50 euros
les hommes vieillissent mieux la métier
d'image c'est un métier de séduction et
je suis désolé mais ça on enfonce
peut-être des portes ouvertes mais un
homme en général de bien moi je suis
plus beau qu'il y a quand j'avais 30 ans
je trouve que là pour le coup c'est
hyper sexiste de dire un truc pareil
c'est la vérité
c'est pas forcément si je mets une femme
de votre âge je sais pas ce que vous
avez quoi 60 chansons
mélanger plusieurs choses et de raisons
en ce qui concerne le ce que dit Laurent
effectivement moi en tant que
téléspectatrice de base qui adore
regarder la télévision sur les grandes
émissions populaires fédératrices je
suis désolé en tant que femme je préfère
voir un mec je me présentais un grand
programme et effectivement qu'on
présenter éventuellement qu'au présenter
avec une fille mais j'irai je regarde
avec plus de réticences un programme
présenté par une femme et alors sur les
films intéressants au cinéma et les
fictions c'est vrai qu'on accepte pas
qu'une femme vieillissent quand elle se
fait trafiquer en lui oh bah ça se voit
qu'elle s'est fait trafiquer les
réalisateurs veulent les engager de
moins en moins et quand elles se font
pas trafiquer Valérie kapristi dans un
caprice dans un téléfilm récent j'ai
entendu plein de gens dire le temps on a
l'impression qu'en fait aussi les femmes
pardon
vas-y Florian faut quand même rectifier
et dire des choses qui existent et
j'adore le journaliste pardon j'ai amené
un peu d'intelligence dans le débat
sexiste mais quoi toujours se donner le
bon rôle et on oublie de dire des choses
que par exemple Léa sal les reines de
France 2 pour la première fois non mais
vous exagérez
Sophie davantage
on peut parler de Flavie Flavie qui est
revenu il y a pas longtemps merci elle a
fait une émission
aujourd'hui c'était quelques noms elles
sont à la télé elle fait l'air tu
pourrais parler des présentatrices de
journaux pardon il y avait pas de
présentatrice de Jérôme il y a encore 30
ans il y avait que des mecs
pardon la hauteur au sujet sur le sujet
c'est qu'effectivement les femmes qui
ont une vraie valeur ajoutée dans le
journaliste un de ces intérêt à toi dur
nous on parle des femmes qui font de
l'animation comme des mecs qu'on
animation et qui sont interchangeables
dès qu'elle vieillissent on les change
point barre et là c'est pas la valeur
ajoutée ça c'est une question aussi
d'énergie j'ai l'impression que quand
oui quand on a besoin de de d'un homme
pour un programme fédérateur du type
Reichmann ou autre c'est aussi
parce qu'il y a une énergie une quelque
chose de très libéré chez l'homme et que
la femme s'auto conditionne de parler du
question qu'elle a reçu etc à se tenir
un peu comme ça très clairement alors
qu'il faut quelqu'un qui l'énergie pour
animer il faut que quand même quelqu'un
qui bouge mais Natacha on parle quand
même de vous notamment une énorme une
star gigantesque de TF1 pendant 10 ans
et je vous adore mais en parle
aujourd'hui de venir faire une chronique
chez moi il y a quand même un truc pas
avec les mecs qui ont été très connus
sur TF1 et qui sont chroniqueurs chez
toi aujourd'hui non mais qu'est-ce que
tu reviens tu fais du prime tu fais des
prime à un million tu fais des prime à
un million je fais des prime parce que
cette personne propose rien parce que
c'est l'opportunité du moment mais en
vrai quand tu m'as appelé il y a un an
c'était pas pour que je fasse une
émission avec sauf que l'opportunité ne
revient jamais pour les femmes il y a
rien de dégradant il y a rien de gênant
c'est une mauvaise foi l'opportunité ne
revient jamais pour les femmes tu le
sais très bien passé 50 ans on n'a pas
le droit pas à la télé une émission
aussi culte et aussi importante que il y
a que la vérité grande pardon de faire
péter les bretelles c'est le format
qu'on achète aujourd'hui c'est pas
batailler fontaine mais c'est pas vrai
et Michel Benoît Benoît et Sophie non
bah moi déjà je suis très content de
voir des hommes dans des grosses
machines moi ça me rassure j'ai été
élevé comme ça oui je vais choqué tout
le monde j'aime les hommes
la plus burné dans les médias qu'on peut
mettre partout pour l'instant c'est
Karine le marché pour être à l'égal de
l'homme sur les grosses machines qu'on
peut voir empruntime après temps en
temps on ressort des bonnes femmes comme
ça
mais à 20h50 ou 21h sur TF1 sauf que tu
fais quoi la question d'énergie oui bien
sûr cette question beaucoup plus
d'énergie et à moins de maladies
qui ont vachement d'énergie et qui
déménagent la baraque simplement moi ça
me rase sur l'homme
juste un mot parce que bon on dit pas
bonne femme on dit femme et juste un mot
aussi c'est un très bon exemple ça dit
quand elle est revenue elle s'est mis un
petit peu loin sur un plateau des robes
très larges basket savait qu'elle espère
massacrer sur les réseaux parce qu'on
allait dire à la grossi à la vieilli
exactement c'est à dire que en fait
quand Jean-Michel dit les hommes
vieillissent mieux en fait c'est pas
qu'il vieillissent mieux c'est qu'on
leur pardonne plus absolument
pas à quel moment tu vieillis mieux tout
tombe enfin bon voilà c'est pareil sauf
qu'on leur parle
c'est les femmes qui sont beaucoup plus
sympathiques et bienveillantes mais avec
les mecs on en sait quelque chose que
nous qui sommes très dur avec les femmes
dès qu'elles ont un truc qui va pas ou
qu'elle grossissent un peu nous
heureusement que les femmes nous aiment
même quand on gros c'est la vie alors
les amis en tout cas on sera on sera
jamais d'accord une chose est sûre de
trois émissions ici on vous remet
Natacha mâle au top au top et maïssan
aussi qui est très jolie et pas que très